what's a machine gun good for fun of  shooting it if you're not in the  military people have automatic weapons  no  oh you don't think so yeah and you like  guns yeah we got to stop the promotion  of the machine gun there you go  and that that would help you on our  petition it's from Machine Gun Kelly to  change his name so he's no longer  glorifying  machine guns what do you think about  background check Kelly that's a new name  seven day waiting period you guys are  dead ass up yeah no cap bro  [Applause]  I don't deal with that sign means we  want you to change your name you want me  to change my name to what we want to  take out the machine guns  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  do you think he's gonna do it I don't  know but message received on his end we  got a shot  hey